l'udc a effectivement ce qui retient
l'attention ce soir ce qui va
certainement être le plus contraignant
aujourd'hui pour les français c'est
cette extension du pass sanitaire que
peut-on retenir le cas oui tout à fait
et c'était la huitième à dresde emmanuel
macron aux français aujourd'hui depuis
le début de la crise ducobu 19 peut-être
la plus importante puisqu'elle et
exprime et vient des projets pour le
long terme
il a même parlé évidemment de 2030 même
site et sur la partie économique donc
pour l'extension du pass sanitaires et
bien dès le 21 juillet pour les lieux de
culture et de loisirs à partir de 12 ans
puis ensuite et bien août avec l'aide
viennent bien sûr des parlementaires
pour les restaurants les cafés c'était
ce que redoutaient les personnes qui ne
voulaient pas de cette vaccination
obligatoire je vous propose d'écouter
emmanuel macron dès le 21 juillet
le pass sanitaire sera étendue aux lieux
de loisirs et de culture
concrètement pour tous nos compatriotes
de plus de 12 ans il faudra pour accéder
à un spectacle un parc d'attractions un
concert ou un festival avoir été
vaccinés ou présenter un test négatif
récents ce pass est disponible sur
l'application tout senti peu vide mais
chacun peut utiliser la version papier
remise au moment de la vaccination à
partir du début du mois d'août le pass
sanitaire s'appliquera dans les cafés
les restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux jeux si dans les avions trains
et cars pour les longs trajets là encore
seuls les vaccinés et les personnes
postées négative pourront accéder à ces
lieux qu'ils soient d'ailleurs clients
usagers ou salariés aujourd'hui seuls
50% des français de plus de 18 ans sont
vaccinés contre le coc vite 19 et le
conseil scientifique estime qu'il
faudrait de 90 à 95% des personnes
qu'ils eurent - soit le coc vide soit
une vaccination pour juguler l'épidémie
emmanuel macron a promis qu'il ne
rendrait pas la vaccination obligatoire
au cours de ces dernières
q sion notamment en novembre puis sur le
média brut en décembre mais les mesures
qu'il s'apprête à prendre sont tellement
incitatives qu'on peut se demander si ça
ne revient pas de fer a obligé et bien
cette vaccination
merci le cas les géants